(upbeat music)
- What's up, guys? Michael here.
The saying, "geek culture is pop culture"
has become a cliche, and with good reason.
Superheroes rule the box office,
video games bring in
more money than movies,
and all the cool kids play tabletop RPGs.
It seems the mainstream has
shaken off its affected smirk
and dived full-force
into unabashed nerd-dom.
What's more, the ways we interact
with pop culture have also changed,
reflecting the behaviors of geek culture
that normies once shunned.
We used to make fun of Trekkies,
and comic book fans were roasted
for obsessing over the
finer details of continuity.
Now, you can't even watch a
movie where cars go vroom!
without taking on a laundry list
of prior movies and spin-offs.
Wanting to play video games for a living
was once equivalent to
wanting to be a Power Ranger.
Now, E-sports stars make a good chunk
of what professional athletes make,
without the concussions.
And going to bat for
your favorite franchise
is now standard practice.
- [Male] I wanna talk
about "Star Craft II",
in many ways the last hurrah
of the single-player RTS
and, if you ask me, the
rightful queen of the genre.
- So how did geek culture
become ubiquitous?
And does geek culture actually still exist
once it's so mainstream?
Get yourself comfy for
this Wisecrack Edition
Is Geek Culture Dead?
Since the beginning, geek
subculture was concerned with
and unified primarily by media,
especially genre fiction,
which means that geek culture
has been inextricably tied
to the concept of fandom.
Important note, geek culture
overlaps with fan culture,
but doesn't encompass all fandom.
Basically, all geeks are fans,
but not all fans are geeks.
Anyway, modern fandom has really
been around since the 1890s
when Sherlock Holmes captivated
the emerging urban middle class.
Holmes fans even protested
when Sir Arthur Conan Doyle
killed off the beloved detective,
so much so that the author
begrudgingly brought him back to life.
While the term "fandom"
was applied to sports
and theater lovers
throughout the 19th century,
sci-fi literature lovers appropriated it
as they developed "much of
the fannish infrastructure,
jargon and language
still used to this day,
according to scholar Francesca Coppa.
Sci-fi fans started communicating
via the letters column of famed
magazine, Amazing Stories.
Soon, they began to
produce their own zines.
Was this geeky behavior? For sure.
But according to scholar Lars Konzack,
geek dom as we know it
today really can be credited
to the culture built by
World War II veterans,
especially engineers and
intelligence officers.
When veterans returned from war
and began their GI
Bill-funded higher education,
they had the time and space to process
what they'd been through.
As Konzack explains, they
expressed their reaction
to their unique experience
by creating and embracing
science fiction novels,
superhero comic books,
and military strategy board games.
"This," Knozack says, "coalesced
into its own, distinctive
alternative intellectual milieu
around the Cold War era."
But modern geeky fandom was
poised to really explode
around 1966, when sci-fi made
the jump from books and movies
to the more accessible TV format.
And fans of Star Trek,
arguably set the blueprint
for geek fandom as we know it today.
Belittled by the mainstream,
they formed a subculture of their own
to express their passion.
Born in part out of the
counterculture movements
to the 1960s, Trekkies
were super grassroots
and self-organized.
They created dedicated conventions,
popularized fan-fic and cosplay,
and, some argue, got
their show a third season.
As technology progressed,
creators could bring ever more
engrossing worlds to life.
And then, of course, Star Wars
hit in '77 and spearheaded
the now-ubiquitous
approach to merchandise.
By now, fandom had attracted
scholarly attention.
Academics initial reactions
to fandom stereotyped
these new fans, much like
they had sports fans,
as being pathological.
It was even commonly suggested
that fans needed psychiatric help.
But, that didn't stop them.
By the 1990's, dedicated fandoms
had become pretty commonplace
for geeky fiction,
all following the grassroots
subcultural example
set by Trekkies.
The growth of the internet
facilitated greater connection
between fans than the
readers of Amazing Stories
could have ever imagined.
By this point, it was possible for people
to have been in a fandom
for most of their lives.
And it was around this time
that fan studies scholars
started pushing back against
prevailing stereotypes.
Most notably, there was Henry Jenkins,
an academic and fellow fan.
Frustrated with the mainstream
stereotype of fandoms
as mindless and anti-social consumers
obsessed with immature stories,
Jenkins explored fandoms ethnographically.
He framed them as communities
rooted in creative engagement
with a given media text,
creating new meanings
to base the social actions
of the subculture on.
Key to this is a
conflicting set of emotions.
To Jenkins, fandom is both fascinated with
and frustrated by the media they focus on.
They're emotionally invested
in the world of the text,
but that investment
also breeds frustration
with the text's inevitable shortcomings.
This fuels acts of creation
like fan fiction and art,
also known as Fan Labor.
Through acts of Fan Labor,
fandoms are essentially tailoring the text
to reflect their own tastes,
views and experiences.
Although it's not just
creative interpretation;
it even extends to acts of evangelism,
like when fandoms organize en masse
to save their favorite shows.
Jenkins labels this
"participatory culture",
where the public has more
agency in the formation
and definition of their culture.
Participatory culture acts as a sort of
grassroots counterpoint to
mindless media consumption.
But, even as smart folks started defending
fans of geek culture,
one thing remained the same,
the mainstream's scorn.
According to scholar Dan Hassler-Forest,
fans had mainly been perceived
by Hollywood film studios
as irritants, niche groups of
excessively invested consumers
whose limited numbers rendered
their voices insignificant.
Films like Tim Burton's 1989 film Batman,
were thus purposely tailored
to attract the largest
mainstream audience,
rather than to pay homage to fans.
According to Hassler-Forest,
that was about to change
with one big-ass franchise,
"Lord of the Rings".
Director Peter Jackson,
savvily embraced the
simmering fan anticipation
for the film.
He gave the blogger behind
fan website, "The One Ring",
a private tour of the set,
let her take photographs,
and eventually relied on her
as a main source of
publicity for the sequels.
This marked what Hassler-Forest calls,
a shifting relationship
between fan culture
and media industries,
where fans were addressed not
only as the ideal consumers
of a commercial fantastic franchise
but also as valuable
contributors to the process.
With the commercial success
of Lord of the Rings,
fans started being viewed as influencers,
who could produce hype
that would ideally bring
in an even larger audience.
This potential mushroomed
as the internet expanded
and media industries started
to rely more and more
on networked cultures
and spreadable media,
according to Hassler-Forest.
What's more, performing fannish behavior
has become less taboo,
which Hassler-Forest argues
is in part due to the
radical individualization
that marks our social media environment.
As a result, a lot more
people are doing fandom.
And there's every reason to
think fans will only continue
to become more important
as Hollywood keeps chasing
the most profitable IP.
Some scholars think fandom
will become so mainstream
as to render the distinction
between fan and average audience member
virtually insignificant.
Now, mainstream media didn't
start embracing fandom
out of the goodness of their hearts.
Stats show that the most
dedicated fans of TV and movies
spend around 45% more than the rest,
for gamers, it's 230%.
What's more, fans vastly
outnumber casual viewers.
Couple that with fans' zealous dedication
to hyping their favorite franchises,
and you can see why no red-blooded exec
could possibly keep ignoring them.
Over the years, geek fandoms have proven
to be a valuable commodity
to media corporations,
Which has meant a fundamental
shift in how fandoms form.
Corporations are now actively
looking to create fandoms
from day one, with different tactics
for different stages of fandom,
all to stir fans into the most passionate,
and profitable stay.
At the same time, geek culture is becoming
increasingly corporatized.
Conventions like New York
Comic Con and Chicago Comic
and Entertainment expo, and so on
are being bought up by ReedPop,
a subsidiary of global events
organizer Reed Exhibitions,
which continues to engulf ever
more once-grassroots events.
At the same time, film studios
and media conglomerates
have increasingly
infiltrated these events,
luring fans with exciting
exclusive previews
that they'll be sure to tweet about.
And now, media corporations
have found ways
to commodify fandom itself
by exploiting Fan Labor.
This takes myriad forms,
Like competitions, where the prize
is your fan-art being used
as promotional material,
or being featured in the movie,
that's also known as unpaid labor,
Or leveraging IP law
against free fan-works,
like short films or game mods,
only to release their
own versions soon after.
Even fan-fic, is being exploited.
Take shipping, the practice
of creating fan-fic
around theoretical
romantic pairings in an IP.
Historically a way for queer fans
to create their own representation,
popular ships are now being
incorporated into marketing
and even alluded to in
the texts themselves,
just to get fans in the door.
But often, it's a trick,
these ships are largely ignored
in favor of straight romances.
This isn't necessarily
the end of the world,
but the iron grip corporations
are starting to have on fandoms
arguably creates problems.
When a corporation all
but controls a subculture,
can you really call it
a subculture anymore?
And what happens when a subculture,
used to operating as outcasts
in opposition to the mainstream,
finds their forum confined
by corporate oversight?
Similarly, subcultures like
those surrounding indie rock,
punk, and emo music have
encountered these same tensions.
Essentially, fandoms used
to play in the woods,
but corporations have paved them over
with a high-fenced jungle gym.
The question, then, poses itself,
when fandom is mainstream,
does it even really exist anymore?
Fans may be courted by corporations,
but do they actually have power,
especially when a few media conglomerates
own almost all of popular culture's IP?
It depends who you ask.
From Jenkins' interpretation,
fandom could be seen as an active way
to invert the increased
consolidation of IP.
He argued that fan-fic in particular,
is a way of the culture
repairing the damage done
in a system where contemporary myths
are owned by corporations
instead of owned by the folk.
This interpretation sees
fans as active creators
and consumers of their
favorite geek media,
rather than passive receptacles
for whatever corporate
media wants them to stan.
This is interesting, because
Jenkins acknowledges,
that the media that fandoms
form around are essentially,
corporate products.
Regardless of the empowering aspects
of Jenkins' proposed
participatory culture,
fandoms are still emotionally invested
in something that
corporations make for profit.
Which is why others argue
that the fan autonomy
celebrated by Jenkins
is something of an illusion.
Some of this has to do with
the power of the mighty IP.
As Simone Murray puts it,
"The ultimate discretion
of media conglomerates
to shut down fan creations
around corporate-owned properties
renders hollow much cultural studies
champion of fans' contrarian impulse".
That is to say, when
Disney ,by way of Marvel,
can sue you for using too many clips
in your reaction video to Ant-Man,
can you actually take
culture into your own hands?
According to Hassler-Forest, not really.
He argues that there is a
grossly asymmetrical relationship
between fans and media producers,
such that fan autonomy
becomes somewhat illusory.
He writes that,
when beloved stories
become highly profitable
global entertainment brands,
they no longer make up a
form of cultural commons
that can be appropriated,
embellished, transformed,
or subverted.
Instead, they become
lucrative corporate franchises
made up of a wide range of commodities,
most of which are dependent upon fans
to achieve their desired commercial value.
That is to say, media producers
have both the power to stop
fans from circulating their arts
and the resources to produce
a gob smacking amount
of content and products.
In both limiting fan production
and aggressively
encouraging fan consumption,
media producers are arguably
co-opting fan culture
while stymieing its expression.
What this argument really spotlights,
is the tension between
the two sides of fandom,
fans as anti-commercial subcultures
organized on a grassroots level,
and fans as rabid consumers
and promoters of corporate IP.
And as fandom becomes
increasingly mainstream,
that tension might just constitute
one of the most important debates
about how we consume media.
But what do you guys think?
Has corporate involvement changed
what it means to be a fan?
Is there still room for geek culture?
Let us know in the comments.
Big thanks to our patrons
for all your support,
and forget to check out our podcasts.
Shove that subscribe button
like it's a nerd at their locker,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(upbeat music)